going to putin going to putin so
you know my mother's side they're from
russia okay so
their their bible was karl marx
communist manifesto so they're from the
stalin lenin era they escaped or baku
azerbaijan armenia and they came to
uh pandar pahlavi which is right on
caspian sea north
uh iran and it's a few hours away from
tehran and we heard stories you know
about who lenin was who stalin was who
these guys were etc etc and then here in
america if if you drop the name putin to
the average person and let's just say
david goes on the streets there's a man
on the street in new york or he doesn't
miami if you ask a hundred people who's
putin they're gonna say what dictator
he's this he's that he's a murderer he's
gonna say all this stuff about him right
now you have actually interviewed with
them i don't know how many hours you
guys were to get it was a project that
took quite a while to do
and four of these interviews were
launched so who is putin to you having
spent one-on-one time with them how
different is it than what we see on tv
how he's portrayed
you probably don't want to hear it but
he's the son of russia in the sense that
he has russian interests or foremost in
his mind as he as would any leader in
any country whether it's the philippines
or
taiwan or this or that i mean he is
cares about his country and he serves it
that's the way he and that's why he's
he's there because people feel
that he's there and it's they talk about
he's he's a tyrant but he wouldn't stay
in office in russia the russia that i
know and many people would agree with
this that it if he was a
monster which is pictured in the west
he'd be out of office because it
wouldn't work
they have this ins
indirect democracy so to speak the
people are not happy things are bad the
guy is out and that's what happened to a
few leaders
so
on that point you know i i went at it
without preconceptions like we talked
about earlier
i'd heard all the stories and of course
i spoke to people who
told me other things among them was
stephen cohen who became i became very
friendly with cohn was the i think the
leading sovietologist in our country he
was studied russia he gave me
point by point all the descriptions of
these murders and who possibly did them
but certainly it would be ridiculous for
putin to have done them because the
motive would have come right back on him
he would have been
i mean it's beyond
the narrative is so
poorly constructed against him by the
cia and it's been a narrative there for
what is it 20 years now
20 years of lying and blaming everything
on russia you have to be
you have to be a little bit more
fair-minded you have to be open to say
that is it possible that oh that russia
has done all this and and we're the good
guys it's like a good versus bad
scenario it feels like a you know
john wayne movie it's not
we're not john wayne
we're
we have been
trying to destabilize russia since uh
1917 actually
when we sent an army there in 1918 19
with the the 16 other armies to take
apart the revolution woodrow this great
democrat woodrow wilson sent the army
then again we we didn't recognize russia
until roosevelt recognized russia in 33.
roosevelt is the one who tried and he
reached out to stalin and he met with
him
they he met with him and he liked him
and he said uncle joe they had fun
together they laughed they met in iran
they got along and roseville had a plan
if he'd lived after april 45 to bring
russia into the into this grand alliance
that he wanted he saw un grand alliance
it was a very
it was a very uh
strong good picture of the world england
would be
u.s china russia
um
it was a tragedy he died in april
because truman came in and
he reversed the points like johnson
after kennedy he reversed the policy
with the russia right away
right away they had a horrible meeting
stalin was felt that this was uh the
opening was over and of course stalin is
not saying he's he's he was a tyrant
that was a tyrant and he was very and he
was a murderer and he killed people but
that doesn't change the effort that
russia made in world war ii and the
sacrifice they made and how they helped
us too so you have to balance the good
and the bad the people who hate russia
of course point to stalin is the most
evil man of all time worse than hitler
so they make a whole scenario about him
but they ignore what the russians
contribution was to world war ii and
stalin frankly held that country
together at that time he was a tough guy
but uh you
you have to make sometimes you have to
lie in bed with people like that to uh
to get what you need
and america has to be realistic about it
you can't be a
child about
comic book heroes so anyway putin is
listen i spent uh i'm limited i spent uh
four trips maybe 30 hours with a man so
and the result you should see it i hope
you see it it's called the putin
interviews it's four hours long
four hours long it was on show time it
still is
and it's available on through other
channels too you can get it probably on
amazon you can rent it or you can buy it
it's a it's
he he answers these questions that we're
dealing with today
ukraine foremost in his mind at that
point this was 2000 right after 14 this
was 16 area and he tells me the whole
story from his point of view even down
to who's firing who who are the people
who are firing shots at medan
it's not it's not pro-russian forces
because they're firing from buildings
occupied by the protesters it's a it's
people who are snipers who are firing at
the crowd killing both policemen and and
protesters
that's the whole point you create it was
like the same thing that happened in
venezuela back
around that time that's a cia technique
color revolution then you then you have
the violence the violence breaks out
somebody's killing somebody but you kill
from both sides you create this
disturbance
and
they killed a lot of cops they killed
protesters and that
kicked off
so who did it
who was firing from those buildings
there was
lots of stories about the neo-nazi gangs
that were coming into kiev from the west
from the west of ukraine
it's most likely them i mean it probably
was them it may have been some foreign
mercenaries too
so there was all that violence is what
creates that mood for
for change so they throw the president
out illegally they they don't have an
election
you know they we install this guy uh
uh
the other victim whoever he was victoria
newland is there from the state
department she's the leader of the
neocon faction uh and the american
ambassador it's all right
we we got the recordings they're talking
about getting rid and she even says [ __ ]
the eu because the eu wants to do it
more legally you know
frankly france and switzerland were
playing a role here very in germany
we're playing a very important role in
trying to make this a transition that
was democratic
it didn't because they were going to
have an earlier election didn't happen
because of the violence
the nazis have much more power in
ukraine than you think the united states
denies it because they say zolensky is a
jew and that's their motivation for
saying well how can they be neo-nazi
that's nonsense neo-nazis were there way
before zolensky and zolensky had no
power in fact when he became president
he had to make a deal with them
he had to make a deal with them because
they're tough people they're not gonna
they are telling the president what to
do
you cannot change the ukraine policies
you have the united states telling you
what to do and you have the neo-nazis
telling you what to do and what it's
it's disgusting that the united states
is condones it doesn't mention him
doesn't talk about them but basically
condones what the nazis the neo-nazis
are doing in ukraine that's what's sick
really sick so when you talk about all
that putin is talking about that he
talks about ukraine and he talks a lot
about nato
this was back then he saw it
for him it's you're putting my back
against the wall i'm going you're
pushing me
that you're strangling me we're
surrounding them
we made the baltics
very aggressive towards them sweet
sweden finland uh poland has been we put
anti-ballistic missiles in poland that's
horrible and romania
and these missiles can be adapted to an
offensive weaponry
and in five minutes could be in moscow
you see from from their point of view
it's they they feel the squeeze you put
his back up against the wall what are
you doing
you're going to create a state either
where
he's going to go to war and he's going
to fight back and he's got the nuclear
weapons to do so
they're pri
they're crude weapons but they're
they're very big strong weapons
hypersonic missiles
we have very
refined weapons we have we have great
weapons too but i wouldn't want to be
there in that war it's it's it's not a
war that makes any sense for the world
and uh he's pushed we're pushing his
into the wall either that or else we'll
get what we want which is
regime change
uh bring in some guy like yeltsin was in
1990 who would work with us
basically cannibalize the country and
allow
allow their resources to be exploited
that's interesting
what you're saying oliver because
one of the techniques that was deployed
at the fall of the berlin wall remember
was reagan putting the pershing missiles
in germany
i remember and it really freaked out
gorbachev oh yeah and they went to
iceland and gorbachev said what do you
want me to do
and reagan said you should have said yes
and so
looking back to the lens
is this kind of that you think
what i'm hearing is you see a playbook
here absolutely absolutely never changed
the the neil conservatives have kept
this playbook alive if you remember the
project for the new american century
that was the the plan to attack all
these countries and get and clean out
the middle east first of all
uh it was a husband of victoria newland
kagan robert kagan who was one of the
project founders you can go up to robert
kagan and you can go to victoria newland
on your board there
uh these are the villains
these are the foster dulleses and alan
questions of the modern era
that her and her husband uh
you know she's a beauty she's a beauty
[Laughter]
no i when i see a face like that it
makes me really
and i i voted for biden and because i
thought you know the uncle joe that he
mellowed you know he can't be as bad as
he used to be when she was for every war
america was in remember he was like he
was a coal warrior
he's never but he never changed he never
he he should be curbing these people
instead of appointing them to
she comes from the hillary clinton
period she uh he's inherited that and he
he let her become under secretary of
state for that region and that is a huge
mistake huge mistake but show me kagan
her her uh
her husband i wonder what their what
their days are like and what their
dinners are like well there's some
you're describing some very strange
bedfellows and what's interesting you
were talking about you know it's an easy
connection one that i've heard and it
seemed very logical about eisenhower's
prophecy about the military-industrial
complex in his departing addresses he
brought it up more than once
uh apparently kennedy took that very
very seriously or already had
predilection in that direction but then
you're talking about the um the
intelligence
the intelligence community and the
ability to get the go-ahead
isn't it interesting that alan dulles
ends up on the warren commission
that's what
i think you can answer that for yourself
it's like the fox is investigating the
chicken coop yeah it's not really a
question it was kind of a reflective
thing
alan dulles did everything in his power
first of all he didn't have a job so he
was he was available to come in for
every session none of the other
members of the commission were able to
do that
dulles uh
supervised followed that thing
everything from the cia was blocked of
importance nothing got through
the the biggest crime of all was that he
didn't even bother to tell the his
fellow commissioners that we had tried
to assassinate castro
didn't tell them so they didn't even
know about our assassination programs
when they started this commission so
where are they going to go
they're in the dark but they didn't have
they had an agenda anyway
it was going to be straightjacket was
jayhadgerhoover said three bullets six
seconds a crazy assassin uh a communist
type
and that was it it was closed that was
over it was there was no investigation
beyond that everything had to fit that
scenario so if you enjoyed this little
segment from the podcast click over here
to watch the entire podcast and if
you've not subscribed to the channel
please do so take care everybody
[Music]